china has held the mantle of the world's
biggest polluter for more than a decade
it emits the most greenhouse gases and
uses more coal than the rest of the
world combine
but in september it make the biggest
climate commitment ever made by any
nation
china's pledge is expected to not only
improve lifestyle and air quality for
urbanites tired of smog
it could also boost the clean energy
business and bring hundreds of millions
of electric vehicles on the road
after president xi jinping's
announcement stalks a chinese renewable
energy giant sword
there are questions about whether china
can really achieve its climate goal
but as beijing pushes ahead with its
plan the growing green superpower could
affect the us
and the rest of the world
china's green energy leap won't be cheap
over the next 30 years
beijing and clean energy companies will
need to spend anywhere between
5 to 20 trillion so we don't know
exactly how much beijing is going to
spend although
it's already spending a lot we do know
that beijing is very good
at stimulating the creation of very
large industries
the first step is ramping up renewable
energy and that's not
impossible because china already has a
lot of solar parks and wind farms
more than any other country but china
needs a lot more
90 of the country's energy has to be
renewable or nuclear by 2050 to achieve
net zero emissions
in past years renewable capacity has
boomed in large part because of
subsidies
and these companies haven't had to
compete in the global marketplace
in a strategy shift beijing wants to
roll back some of that direct support
for companies
you kind of slowly dial down the support
and only the
companies that are actually of high
quality and are able to
innovate will be able to survive that
[Music]
having renewable energy on tap provides
a clean source of power for its electric
vehicles
china already has the most in the world
and wants 300 million
on the road by 2050. china has the
resources to do these kind of
top-down government pushes they've just
mandated that a certain percentage of
all government-owned fleets like a
certain amount of the buses a certain
amount of the corporate fleets
or the government have to be ev's and so
that kind of creates a
baseline kind of structural level demand
but beijing has also cut subsidies for
people in the market to buy electric
vehicles
as well as for local manufacturers as a
result
companies like byd and bike have seen
their sales slump
while tesla has been able to speed ahead
to become the market leader in china
but still beijing is keeping foreign
automakers in check by requiring them to
use chinese-made batteries
this kind of policy has helped china get
a good grip on the supply chain for
lithium-ion batteries
which accounts for more than half of
global production
but that advantage could slip there's a
lot of lithium
out there in the world if lithium prices
start to go up i think there'll be a lot
of capital coming from a lot of
different places to develop those
deposits
i think it will be actually would be
quite hard for china to kind of dominate
the control of lithium
renewables can only have an impact if
china moves away from coal
but it won't be easy to switch off these
plants there's a lot of
banks that have lent to those coal
plants that's potentially a financial
problem there's still a fair amount
people working
in the coal industry so there's going to
be a lot of kind of best
interests in keeping coal alive
in some form or another in china enter
carbon capture technology which would
allow some coal plants to stay
online the technology would remove co2
from the atmosphere so it can be stored
or repurposed
many of these techniques have been
around for decades but it's still
incredibly expensive
costing about 43 dollars to capture one
ton of co2
that means for a country of 1.4 billion
people
where each person emits seven tons of
carbon dioxide every year
the cost would be astronomical so
beijing will have to make polluters
responsible for their own carbon
emissions
by making them pay for it you're also
going to have to create an incentive
to make it more expensive to
produce emissions by burning coal or
other forms of fossil fuels and so a
real carbon trading
program in china you know that would be
a huge incentive for
coal producers to invest in carbon
capture technology
in october chinese officials announced
plans to expand its emissions trading
program
in the next five years while the current
pilot schemes cover sectors like steel
and cement
the nationwide one would bring in heavy
emitters like the aviation industry
china's 2060 goal could have ripple
effects
its large-scale investments could
further drive down the cost of cleantech
around the world
the same way solar panel prices have
plunged more than 80 percent
in part because of the dominance of
chinese firms
but china isn't alone in thinking about
this energy transition
its relatively smaller neighbors japan
and south korea set a 2050 deadline for
carbon neutrality
and some european players are investing
heavily in renewables
while trump has signaled that he sees an
energy transition as a threat to the oil
and gas industry
joe biden has proposed a 2 trillion
climate change plan
these competitors and countries could
also grow increasingly wary of china
there will be a worry both in terms of
subsidies and in china producing things
below cost then also
being too dependent on china for their
energy supply